aquí tengo varias matrices la primera
matriz es a que tiene m renglones y n
columnas la segunda matrices b que tiene
en renglones y m columnas y sus
transpuestas que recuerden simplemente
es el resultado de intercambiar
renglones por columnas ok ahora la
entrada que estaría aquí en la matriz a
ahí ese color está mal voy a hacer este
de entrada que está aquí en la matriz a
sería el máximo renglón hijo teshima
columna así que sería amj la entrada que
estaría aquí sería el enésimo renglón
y la j décima columna sí que es la bn j
muy bien entonces quiero definir dos
matrices nuevas quiero definir la matriz
c
matriz sé que va a ser el producto de la
matriz a por la matriz b qué dimensiones
va a tener pues primero noten que está
en el número de columnas en la es igual
al número de renglones en b así que el
producto está bien definido y la matriz
se va a tener dimensiones igual a los
extremos así que va a ser una matriz de
m por m va a ser matriz de m por m
bien y también también quiero definir la
matriz de vamos a hacerlo acá bajito
que va a ser el producto de b
transpuesta por a transpuesta de
transpuesta por a transpuesta y que
dimensiones va a tener de nuevo el
número de columnas en vez transpuestas
es igual al número de renglones en la
transporta así que el producto está bien
definido y voy a tener dimensiones o de
va a tener dimensiones igual a los
extremos m por m
m por m muy bien noten que si la matriz
ce tiene la forma general
la puede escribir como se 1 1 1 2
así hasta c 1 m
esa sería mi primer renglón el segundo
renglón sería c 2 1 por 0 2 2 hasta c 2
y aquí bajaría hasta llegar a cm1 m2
hasta se m m
ahora bien una entrada general en esta
matriz una entrada se y j qué forma
tiene quiero encontrar la forma de esta
entrada de la entrada más general
posible la entrada se y j
pues la entrada se y j
la entrada ce y j de la matriz se la
puedo obtener como el producto interior
de la décimo renglón de la matriz a este
de aquí este es el vigésimo renglón de
la matriz
con su producto interior con la jota
décima columna de la matriz b
con esto de aquí entonces quién sería
sería a y 1 por b 1 j ya hay 1 por b 1 j
más hay 2 por b 2 j
y 2 x de 2 j y así continuaría hasta
y n por b n j
ahora que hay de la matriz de que hay de
esta matriz de pues de nuevo la matriz
de la puede escribir como
de 11 de de 12
así hasta de 1 m y hasta aquí llegaría
hasta de m m en general
lo mismo que arriba pero ahora quiero
enfocarme en quién sería la entrada de j
normalmente uso jota para escribir
columnas y para describir renglones pero
en este caso quiero hacerlo al revés así
que quién sería la entrada de jota y en
esta matriz de pues sería el resultado
de tomar el producto interior de el
décimo renglón de be transpuesta que
sería estoy aquí
recuerden que en este caso como esta es
la matriz transpuesta de b
es la matriz traspuesta eve
así que los índices están al revés y de
hecho esta es la matriz transpuesta de
así que también los índices están al
revés pero bueno la entrada de j iba a
ser el producto de este renglón
la matriz be transpuesta del décimo
renglón con la y encima columna de a
transpuesta con esta de aquí
muy bien entonces cuánto es eso pues
sería de 1 j por hay uno que como esos
dos números como tan puede escribir como
hay uno por b 1 j luego ver más b 2 j
por ahí 2 de nuevo como estos dos
números como tan puede escribir eso como
hay 2
por b 2 j
y así continuaría continuaría hasta
llegar a bmj por ahí en cuando que es lo
mismo hay n por b nj y aquí quizás ya se
están dando cuenta de algo curioso
para empezar para empezar este renglón
de aquí es igual a esta columna de acá y
este renglón de acá es igual a esta
columna de acá así que en realidad estas
dos cosas estas dos cosas son iguales
así que de hecho pueden comparar aun hay
uno por b 1 j
hay uno por b 1 j + hay 2 por b 2 j +
hay 2 por b 2 j así que en general se y
j es igual a de j
y esto es cierto
cierto
para todas las entradas para todas las
entradas
pero eso que me dice eso me dice que la
entrada que está en la en el décimo
renglón y en la décima columna en esta
matriz es igual a la entrada que está en
el argot en el jote ximo renglón y la y
encima columna de esta matriz de eso es
la definición de transpuesta así que en
realidad esto me está diciendo que se es
igual a de transpuesta y
equivalentemente que d es igual a ser
transpuesta recuerden que la matriz
traspuesta simplemente es el resultado
de intercambiar columnas por renglones
pero bien quién era c pues se era el
producto de la matriz a con la matriz b
y quién era de d
era el resultado de multiplicar a b
transpuesta por a transpuesta así que en
efecto esto me está diciendo eso me está
diciendo
desigual hace transpuesta así que se
transporta es igual a
por b transpuesta pero eso es igual a d
pero el de es de transpuesta x a
transpuesta así que en efecto lo que
acabo de probar es que la matriz
traspuesta del producto de dos matrices
es el producto de las tras puestas en
orden invertido
es decir la matriz a por la matriz b
transpuesta es lo mismo que la matriz b
transpuesta por la matriz a transpuesta
y en general esto se puede generalizar
hacia cualquier número de matrices
bastante fácilmente por ejemplo si yo
quisiera escribir puedes descubrir quién
es la transporta de la matriz x por la
matriz por la matriz zeta si quisiera
obtener la transpuesta de eso pues el
resultado sería z transpuesta x de
transpuesta por x transpuesta no voy a
probar esto pero es un ejercicio
sencillo así que se los dejo de tarea
hasta la próxima